ah
[Música]
y
las casas de ópera las salas de
conciertos han estado cerradas en
argentina desde el inicio de la
cuarentena hace más de 5 meses sin
embargo para no perder contacto con su
público los artistas y los teatros han
estado publicando material en internet
de archivo y también producciones nuevas
grabadas en las casas de los músicos y
de los cantantes los hechos por ejemplo
el teatro colón de buenos aires que
están mis espaldas y que han logrado de
este modo llegar a un nuevo público un
público que además no quieren perder
cuando vuelvan con los espectáculos
presenciales algo que esperan poder
hacer tal vez al aire libre por ejemplo
a fin de año y por supuesto no los
quieren perder en 2021 cuando tienen la
esperanza de volver a hacer espectáculos
en el interior con sala llena como en el
pasado
[Música]
en españa las propuestas culturales se
reinventan para garantizar en la
seguridad sanitaria sin perjudicar más a
un sector que ya se vio muy afectado por
el confinamiento muchos espectáculos
ahora mismo se hacen al aire libre con
sillas es distanciadas pero hay otras
propuestas por ejemplo el ayuntamiento
de barcelona- ya avisó de que para las
fiestas de la ciudad la mercè que se
celebra a finales de septiembre pues
todo el mundo podrá ver conciertos
espectáculos y actos culturales desde su
casa ya que se retransmitirán por la
televisión y en madrid pues en la
comunidad acerca todavía más la música
clásica al gran público al dejar en
youtube un concierto de la orquesta y
coro de la comunidad de madrid
interpretando temas clásicos un vídeo
que es grabado desde el escenario para
acercar más el espectador al concierto
sin salir de su casa
[Música]
por fin de nuevo conciertos en la
filarmónica de berlín así con estas
palabras la propia orquesta explicó su
regreso este viernes tras la pausa
forzada por la crisis de coronavirus el
regreso ha sido como tantos otros
aspectos de la vida social en estos
momentos todo menos habitual la orquesta
explicó que el programa de esta nueva
temporada que está basado en un
repertorio alemán y austriaco debió ser
reducido y que incluso algunas de las
piezas debieron ser reemplazadas para
poder garantizar la distancia mínima
entre los músicos para los espectadores
también se anunciaron cambios
importantes las salas de concierto solo
podrán estar llenas hasta un máximo de
25% no se podrán vender bebidas ni habrá
pausas durante los conciertos y los
espectadores deberán usar una mascarilla
hasta que estén ubicados en sus puestos
la filarmónica de berlín una de las más
importantes y reconocidas del mundo
explicó que estos cambios irán
inicialmente desde agosto hasta octubre
y que más adelante se explicarán las
condiciones para los conciertos de
noviembre y diciembre
[Música]